first before we get started the only
reason I get to do this interview and be
it TIFF it's cuz we partnered up with
House of Aurora and I wanted to give a
huge thank you to House of Aurora for
making all this possible because TIFF is
expensive and I like having a great
partner so thank you I really appreciate
it thank you for must too you know it is
important because you know supporting
movies that do not have like a 50
million dollar PA campaign it matters to
me and you know I want to be able to
support you know what I mean we love
that yeah you know that thank you
also and this might sound but like you
know I want to support more women
directors and the only reason that can
you know but we're off on a tangent the
first thing I would like to ask you when
did you decide to star in every movie
yet can you tell me oh god man I didn't
even realize I was making the decision I
guess see what happened is that this is
all the culmination of about three and a
half years of work that happens to be
coming out at the same time oh this is
not gonna be the norm I just want to put
that out there going forward you're not
gonna see this much of me it's really
exciting one of the things I I'm very
happy you guys made this movie because
you are showing a side of the story that
never gets seen it's I think so many
people don't realize this story since so
many people watching this will not have
seen movie yet can you sort of describe
and I know it's generic and I'm sorry
but we've talked a little bit about what
it's about
yeah so on the surface um this story
looks at a 15 year old afro German girl
she's half white what Hitler would call
Aryan and born of an African French
father and it's the story of one year in
her life where she comes of age in 1944
Berlin under Hitler's rule and what you
see in the story is her living through
and with alongside various relationships
in her life
mother her brother as well as a Hitler
Youth boy who's played by Georgia Makai
and his his his journey towards finding
his identity is a mirror of what is
actually happening with Lena who is
living in this world where she is not
she's not part of a group that is
targeted for mass destruction in the way
that the Jews were mass murder but on an
individual basis
these afro German the Afro Germans live
very difficult uncertain lives but they
live these lives in local German cities
and towns and half their family were
part of the structure often that was
creating the Nazi Germany that we read
about in books today so they had these
kind of intrinsic relationships with the
local German world but they also weren't
belonging they weren't fully belonging
and they didn't live in communities
where they saw themselves reflected in
any way shape or form it was relative
isolation so it's the Ritz really the
story of how she goes from girl to woman
against you know this world that has
gone crazy for the three of you talk a
little bit about what your reaction was
reading the script for the first time
and what you know what was it about the
script that said I really want to be a
part of this I think emma has this
incredible ability to weave narratives
that tell lessons in a really concise
manner and I think there's so many
different dynamics explored in this film
that I can't even begin to summarize all
of them I think that each dynamic each
scene each moment is intentional and
reveals another layer about identity
about nation about race and she doesn't
just really seamlessly so when I read
the script I was really drawn to that
and the amount of metaphors it existed
within it the worst deal we were still
pulling back in the midst of filming I
also think that Lena story and and the
way that she understands her identity
and relates to it and how that shifts
from the beginning of the film to the
end is really compelling and also
relatable I think at first you see this
girl who doesn't understand her place in
the world or at least doesn't have a
full understanding of the world within
which she exists and you see her gain an
understanding of her place of her
isolation of what she represents in her
country and what her country is for me I
think it's what struck me is it's a
really personalized story it's a story
of individualism in a mass community and
and how that resonates you know a ripple
in the pond you throw a stone and
there's a report and I think we see
these characters go through go through a
space and time which we call history
which is not exactly history and we get
to experience that and so this is a
subjective film it's a film that you
experience and I think that's what's
beautiful that for me it was like
through a most beautifully crafted to
get this that is the questions of
identity that it raised that it raises
socially and then for me personally and
having then that understanding that
those two reflect each other that you
kind of the personal questions of
identity then reverberates to a social
level if you don't address them and take
responsibility for them and that I
thought was really important to explore
personally and socially you're dealing
with some intense sometimes dark subject
matter what is it like on set what was
it like on set making this what did that
permeate into the energy in between
filming or was it still you know what I
mean I do I mean I think that and
because of the subject matter
I'm it's true but it was emotional we
did go through
you know just the relationship between a
B and a mandalas characters as mother
and daughter is emotional the
relationship between George and Amanda's
character is emotional and it as Abby
puts so brilliantly you know on an
intimate level but we but we were we
were dealing with this we were dealing
with this massive moment in time and we
were in spaces that that there was
nothing we could do we couldn't get away
from it and so I think we actively
worked hard actually to keep ourselves
both respectful of the circumstances
that we were in and the story that we
were telling but also to kind of really
be the opposite of the world that this
story is about so it was for me as a
filmmaker
it was in it it was a very healing I'm
supportive environment I know everybody
says this when they come and sit on the
sofa like I know this is what everybody
says but it for me it really was like
family I've never heard anyone say I
know I'm gonna be the first it was it
was like family and it was very there
was a never a time where I felt like and
sometimes you can feel like you're
pushing a boulder uphill sometimes you
can you know you can be in situations
where you're trying to communicate a
vision to an actor and they just don't
want to hear it
that don't worry as I still get my way
because I get to but the point is that
just that just never ever ever happened
here each of these people were partners
in the vision and I keep saying you know
like I conceived by myself I conceived
this piece by myself someone got me
pregnant yeah - it's all it was always
your baby right it was my baby but you
all helped yeah like you everyall these
keep you well we helped raise it like
you definitely gave new birth to a baby
I don't know I felt like we were all
pushing we were just nice
okay okay but you and nannies with like
real love so for me what what I think
what was great is that each of these
actors on the sofa with me had had
invested in their characters and their
story and I think that makes a huge
difference and there was a huge amount
that one when I was an actress back in
the day many many years ago I was self
aware and I had no concept of anything
other than what would it look like for
me to step into this character and what
I think brilliant actors do is they
don't care they just lose themselves and
that's what the each of these did every
single day without the fear that they
wouldn't come back and so in between
shots they could be themselves again and
we could have normal conversations and
then we'd have to switch back into it
and I think that that was necessary
because this world that we were in was
relentless yeah I can't imagine I'm also
and this is I think movies like this
about world war 2 and this is a little
bit me putting in myself in the
interview and but I think it's important
every year that we make a movie like
this because it seems like and maybe you
can comment on this that the real world
like modern day people just but they
just forget like they just deny things
that happened and I think it's so
important that movies like this dealing
with the subject matter you know
reminding these are real stories this
really happens yeah I don't think it's
exactly a denial I just think it's lack
of education to be honest and I think I
think sometimes like you know we all go
through different schooling and
education systems and you know depending
on the teacher you have like I remember
in year five and six I had a pretty
sorry history teacher but a pretty
terrible history teacher but in your
eight nine had incredible one mm-hmm
you know and so so this is education
though all this stuff is absorbed
through your teachers the people your
mentors and in a way armor has been our
mentor through this journey so what
we've learned what we've absorbed is
because we have a great leader a great
teacher jerk oh I'm just gonna say I
feel like in moments of social upheaval
and chaos he sometimes forget to look at
history because we have this notion that
it's
the first time that it's happened and
that's definitely not the case and so it
does feel really a critical at moments
like this to look at the past and see
what happened history repeats itself
that's for sure yeah absolutely
Oh what did you learn from any early
screenings that impacted the finished
film wow that's such a good question
interesting oh my god what did we learn
he didn't change very much I've worked
on films that did change I mean what I
learned about the screenings that didn't
really change the film was that um
unlike the other films that I made
people people were finding it difficult
to come back into this world from the
movie I think that the movie is
completely unexpected for many audiences
and not not just because Lena is a child
of color place within the center of you
know Nazi Germany but because you know
it's often sold as a love story and and
it is it has a lot of love in this but
it's it's not it's not an aspirational
love story
it's not the love that you go out to
seek when you leave the cinema and so I
think there were what I learned was how
stunned audiences were by the work and
how much time they needed once they saw
the movie to come back into this world
and to really kind of gather their
thoughts and I think I learned um why
it's important to tell these stories
because you know when you do a test
screening you have all kinds of people
all kinds of levels of education or in
the audience professors through to you
know college students and when you find
that people who you know we have an
amazing professor who's a consultant on
this film a professor ebro's and half
and she was stunned by the end of this
film even though she's a professor of
German history and her speciality is the
black experience during the Holocaust
she was still stunned by how it made her
feel in her what she said to me is you
know to to study it is one thing to
watch it as
and it's an experience is completely
different and I think that that that's
what I learned and in that I learned
really the importance of the story the
importance of film you know um you were
almost out of time before you leave I
would like to everyone he's been coming
through has been playing something
called get to know your tip attendee
promise these are harmless questions and
they're fun for the three actors what TV
show would you love to guest spot on and
what TV show would you love to guess
direct strings totally people have set
mash and like ships oh my oh my god it's
so pretty teen drama it's very very
British yeah I'd like to be on insecure
[Music]
too so I'm just I'm gonna start like
inserting them I love that put it out to
you come on at baby I don't know I don't
have my honestly I have to be really
honest I grew up 170 acres in the middle
of nowhere with no television I do not
watch telly I just have to be totally
honest sorry my looks die in the kisser
absolutely Handmaid's Tale
goodnight what film scared you as a kid
Oh signs you're gonna be like an you are
young don't think she's not scared of
anything
oh man oh wait what's the Halloween
movie with the three witches oh you
spoke Bambi terrified me
well yeah the lasas pretending yeah the
lux is deep man unless doom right and I
see a little Bambi figure rain sorry you
just terrified me completely Oh what is
the background photo on your phone
mine is um two sofas gone for sunset so
fat Malibu the home screen that comes
with screen okay mine is um the secret
wedding that my husband and I had before
the wedding that everybody thought was
our wedding
so in Vegas it's the private this woman
is a romantic you know what TV show have
you watched all the way through more
than once if any cuz Band of Brothers
oh wow well and Remmy shut that Remi LDP
oh and that's to actually show this yeah
yeah yeah he did
okay I'm sorry I'm so I know they're
Arrested Development
oh my god all the way through husband
more than one Handmaid's Tale okay
have you watched it have you watched any
movie more than 20 times yes Taylor's
death
what's up Ferris Bueller's I love that
the Disney animated Jungle Book
yeah The Godfather but I always will
sleep that's why people die it's like as
I was it's like my nap time I'm like
that's terrible
I could never know I love it I love it I
just I can't as hits me and I'm like
sure they're like their Godfather
yeah like okay yeah or The Godfather -
okay yeah I'm sorry either/or is
basically like you know a lullaby daddy
dancin probably about 42 times right now
right
have any of you seen something more than
50 times no no yeah do you own any movie
or TV show props
no I don't I have Lena shoes what I mean
it did you borrow them or were you given
I do I have the Vice mother ring that he
gave me I also have a nice Miami 4 so we
wait there's more than 2
[Laughter]
[Music]
wait so who has rings so the three of
you live rings that's my ring I'm just
forget you wondering we get you a mug
wear that you know man you can make it
in goal that's totally I mean I don't
know what to do with that I'm like what
do I do with this ring is what it means
in the movie yeah I've never actually
worn anything you know I just I just
look at it just look at it yeah on that
note I could ask you a million other
things but you have more interviews to
do I just want to say sincerely Congrats
on the movie I'm really happy you guys
made this and happy for you guys thank
you again for coming into the studio
have a fantastic day thank you thank you
so much
[Music]